offensive messages Tucker Carlson sent
showing contempt for Fox News management
and colleagues were a major factor in
the company's decision to oust him
Monday according to people familiar with
the matter the move took Carlson off the
air a shock to the host and his large
audience making the previous Friday's
show his last and we'll be back on
Monday in the meantime have the best
weekend with the ones that you love and
we'll see you then culturally it's a big
deal because Tucker Carlson was one of
the most well-known TV personalities and
the highest rated Prime Time host here's
a look at the private messages that led
to Carlson's surprise ouster and what's
next to the former host and the network
ahead of Fox's defamation trial against
Dominion voting systems people familiar
with the matter say Fox News lawyers
presented Carlson with what they thought
was good news they told him the court
would redact from illegal filing the
time he called a senior Fox News
executive the sea word but Carlson
wasn't impressed he told his colleagues
he wanted the world to know what he said
about the executive internal messages
many of which were from Tucker Carlson
to other colleagues were made public in
the discovery process and some of those
ended up being redacted but in them Mr
Carlson made disparaging remarks about
some of his colleagues and other people
at the network
the court filings also revealed an
exchange where Carlson called for the
firing of a Fox news reporter for
fact-checking Donald Trump's false
claims about the 2020 election please
get her fired Carlson wrote it's
measurably hurting the company in
another message Carlson is shown
complaining about the Network's news
coverage including its decision to call
Arizona for Joe Biden on Election night
according to one document he wrote we
devote Our Lives to building an audience
and they let Chris Wallace and Leland
Vitter wreck it and included an
obscenity in the messages Carlson also
made disparaging comments about on-air
guests and former president Donald Trump
he wrote in a January 2021 text message
that he was very close to being able to
ignore Trump most nights and that I hate
him passionately although many portions
of the Dominion court documents are
redacted there was concern among Fox
Executives that if the redacted material
were to become public it would lead to
further embarrassment for the network
and the parent company and on Monday the
network said it would part ways with the
popular host Tucker found out about 10
minutes before it was announced by the
company Fox news media and Tucker
Carlson have mutually agreed to part
ways Carlson declined to comment on his
departure within Fox people familiar
with the matter said reservations had
been mounting about risks Carlson
presented for the network Landing Blue
Chip advertisers for his show was an
issue Fox struggled with getting
advertisers at 8 pm on Tucker's show
partially because of controversial heat
remarks he made on a number of different
topics his commentary had grown more
extreme and expanded Beyond a
conservative viewpoint on politics
female athletes are losing NCAA
championships to men dressing up as
women in order to cheat their way to
Victory Democrats hate the police
because they don't control the police
very simple so what is equity
well tonight finally we know what it is
equity it turns out is racism Carlson
trafficked in what critics and even some
higher-ups within Fox felt was thinly
veiled racism such as this recent show
where he's talking about one of the
Tennessee lawmakers protesting for
stricter gun control Justin Pearson
wasn't white that's probably how he got
into Bowdoin in the first place but he
did a fantastic impression of it what a
nice young man as he considered the
apprenticeship program at Citibank the
former host is also a defendant in a
separate lawsuit that was filed last
month by Abby grossberg a former
producer for Carlson I was hoping that
it would be more professional and what
he was portraying on air was just a show
and unfortunately that wasn't the case
the Abby grossberg lawsuit against Fox
and Tucker is also named as a defendant
in that suit
describes a culture of misogyny and
religious discrimination at the network
Carlson had no comment on the lawsuit
Fox at the time said it hired
independent outside counsel to invest
investigate the concerns raised by
grossberg Fox and News Corp the parent
company of the Wall Street journal's
publisher share common ownership Carlson
now off the air is declined to comment
on his future plans some people have
speculated that he might take on a
career in politics some people have
talked about you know him launching his
own media Venture of some sort or
joining another network but he hasn't
commented on what he's going to do next
for Fox News his ouster leaves a prime
time hole the network is currently
relying on a rotation of hosts until it
names a permanent anchor for the APM
slot historically when anchors have left
Fox the network has survived there are a
number of examples of really prominent
people who have let them left the
network and launched their own careers
Megyn Kelly Bill O'Reilly Glenn Beck
but Fox nonetheless has found talent to
replace them
[Music]